هذا وقال القياده في قوه الحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه بالسودان وهي الدين
ابراهيم ان الحوار هو الالي الوحيده
لانهاء الازمه السودانيه
لابد من وقفال والاجتهاد الى الحوار
الحوار هو الاليه الوحيده لانهاء الازمه
السياسيه
الى تدمير يعني البلاد
لبنائها مجددا
ومن جانبه قال القيادي في قوه الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي محمد الهادي
محمود ان على رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان حميد الا ينظر الى
مصالحهما الشخصيه داعيا اياهما الى الجلوس
وايجاد الحلول المناسبه لتجنيب السودان
حربا اهليه
يكفي الشعب السوداني من دماء خلال
الثلاثون عام الماضيه الان نحن نتطلع
اليوم ننظروا
لمصالحهم الشخصيه ولا للطموحاتهم في الحكم
ما اسوا ان تحكم على على هذه الدماء دماء
غاليه عزيزه هي عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
عزيزه لهوان الكعبه اهون هذه الامام من
امس لهيك عن الدماء الكثير التي نزف الشعب
السوداني نقول نحن الان لا حل اي حرف لا
بد ان ان تحل في الحوار يجب ان لا نطيل
امه هذه الحرف